Aiuto Aiuto
Sono stata in prigionata da Bowser nella
prigione di Super Mario Spero che Mario
venga a salvarmi da questa prigione di
Bowser
Mario non riuscirà mai a salvarti cara
la mia bici lo vedremo secondo me Mario
sta proprio arrivando
a salvarle
e adesso io vado a raccogliere un altro
po' di Miami Preziosi fu
nghetti Ciao
così si arriva Mario avrà più
possibilità di liberarmi non so se non
c'è Bowser sarà meno pericoloso
Challenge per voi Provate a lasciare mi
piace entro 5 secondi 5 4 3 2 1 8 è un
po' scaduto ci siete riusciti
cosa è successo
mezzo pieno di ostacoli di trappole
messi da Bowser guarda
Non ti preoccupare It's a me Mario
Eccolo sapevo che si sarebbe sfracellato
al primo tentativo dai Mario hai ancora
due vite
forza Mario bravo
Forte
adesso non mi resta che arrivare lì ma
serve la chiave Sì infatti per liberarmi
da questa prigione serve la chiave
dobbiamo trovare la chiave in questa
stanza Guarda adesso adesso troverò la
chiave Mario Dov'è la chiave
Dai dai Prendi le chiavi Mario u
Sbrigati prima che torni chi Ah vabbè
vado a prendere le chiavi vai Presto
presto
[Musica]
fresco
[Risate]
sono sempre migliori
[Musica]
non so se riuscirò a liberarmi aspetta
Ho un'idea
sei tornato anche ma tanto bene
Questa è la tua ultima vita vi mostrerò
col dirvi un'altra volta con la mia arma
e tu avrai perso
no no no no no no grazie
Beach
bravissima Ok adesso Adesso vengo a
salvarti
sbrigati però perché non l'hai messo KO
è solo temporaneamente bloccato quindi
Devi sbrigarti Sì sì ho le chiavi Le
chiavi ce
la faccio picchiare svegliato
baudelago Sbrigati io ho aperto la porta
scappa
No dai venite qui
no venite qui venite qui qualcuno
[Musica]
guarda una serena è un parco giochi solo
per noi
ma Chi l'avrà messo qua Boh non lo so Ah
Vabbè proviamo l'altalena
[Risate]
[Musica]
È bellissimo questo parco giochi Chissà
chi l'ha messo qua per
[Musica]
Mario Mario
torna qui
Bowser sì
che scappiamo Allora credo che non sia
un parco giochi questo ma è un livello
da superare e dobbiamo anche scappare da
Bowser
[Musica]
vado
a steccati perderai tutte le tue vite Ma
hai ragione ma guarda lì forse posso
prendere delle altre vite Sbrigati
Bravissimo Hai preso due vite in più Ora
sei quasi fuori pericolo Adesso andiamo
avanti però sta arrivando pausa sbrigati
Stai attento principessa Il primo è il
più difficile arrivo Mario Devo solo
prendere queste vite
no Bitch ti avevo detto che ero
difficile da quello Dai riprova
bravissimo
[Risate]
[Musica]
vediamo cosa c'è dentro
questo lo conservo per dopo
continuiamo la stage arrivo Mario
bouncer è arrivato Mario Sbrigati non
abbiamo più tempo fa
Guarda Mario Luca lascio vieni qui
Bowser ha preso la principessa
dove la sta portando
Ciao Mario
devo andare a salvare la principessa
subito
torna qui no
[Musica]
presto devo saltare nella piattaforma
operatrice
adesso devo aspettare la fitline ma
quello è Mario devo fare prima di lui va
avanti
Vado arrivo Qui bravo
[Musica]
Ok vado
Oh no la principessa è andata per prima
c'è anche Bowser dietro sono entrati
entrambi nella piattaforma devo andare
io adesso Slime
[Musica]
Oh no ho perso la vita e adesso
devo aspettare che torni la zipline
Questa volta però non devo cadere
altrimenti Avrò perso il gioco mi rimane
solo una vita Infatti Ok
Questa volta non cascherò almeno non ci
proverò
uh wow
[Musica]
e anche se Mario venisse a salvarti che
cosa potrebbe fare sconfiggerti
sconfiggere
la mamma è impossibile questo non potrà
mai succedere Mario
la
mia cosa Ah così impari
Spero che Mario arrivi subito
e adesso sconfiggerò anche
cosa hai girato ha tirato l'aria Cosa
credi che può farmi l'aria può solo
alimentare le mie fiamme
e adesso stupido Mario Guarda i miei
attacchi
non ci sei riuscito Bowser
No no no
Rezzo è quello che vuoi allora
vieni qui qua Mario assolutamente fare
qualcosa Se solo riuscissi a liberarmi
da queste corde
Forse posso farcela
[Musica]
non mi prende mai paura
spiegami come fanno i veri eroi
ah ah
ce l'ho fatta Ora devo andare ad aiutare
Mario
[Musica]
ripara tutti e adesso
sì
Bowser regna Oh no
non sono riuscito a salvarti sto
perdendo l'ultima vita
[Musica]
sono l'unica salvezza di Mario
[Applauso]
[Musica]
questo Apri qua
guarda
[Musica]
[Risate]
Ma come hai fatto no sei stato aiutato
da beach da solo non puoi nulla vero
credi di poter sconfiggermi credi di
poter sconfiggere il grande
Bowser Ah non ci riuscirai mai perché la
mia
Dov'è la mia arma Ehi Bowser Stai forte
cercando questa
e ora beccati Qui no
[Musica]
ah ah ah ah
ah ah ah
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
[Musica]
Sì
Challenge completata abbiamo finito la
moto e voi Mi raccomando lasciate un mi
piace E ora vi lasciamo Qua quattro
caselline per cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quello
che preferite eh Buona visione Ciao
[Musica]